[Música]
investigando para hablar hoy con ustedes
me di cuenta que tal vez sea una persona
a teléfono
antolí fóbica seguramente se estarán
preguntando qué es la tele o fobia como
su nombre lo indica esta es una fobia
muy peculiar en la que una persona le
teme a ser imperfecto o equivocarse
generalmente cuando esta persona
considera que fracasa o comete algún
error suele reaccionar con un pico de
ansiedad o de estrés y éstas suelen
volverse extremadamente perfeccionista
obsesivas y auto exigentes yo me
considero una persona perfeccionista
autoexigente y meticulosa y nunca me ha
gustado cometer errores sólo por el
hecho de satisfacer las expectativas de
la sociedad
además esto de cometer errores me ponía
en un lugar incómodo
pero más tarde me di cuenta de que ese
lugar incómodo no lo había creado yo
sino que había sido creado por las
personas que me rodeaban
generalmente cuando cometo algún error
le suelo echar la culpa a otra persona
pero rara vez a mí misma aunque no lo
crean hay estudios que indican que sólo
una minoría suele asumir sus errores y
el resto se los echará de más porque
tendemos a hacer esto porque nos cuesta
tanto asumir nuestros errores
sin embargo pareciera que la perspectiva
del error está empezando a cambiar por
ejemplo en la entrada hay un cartel de
cambridge que dice comete errores
esta frase inspiradora que propone una
de las instituciones más prestigiosas
del mundo sugiere que no le tengamos
miedo a cometer errores no le tengamos
miedo a hacer las cosas que nos gustan
sin embargo están esas personas que nos
critican que los busquen nos juzgan
juzgan nuestros errores
entonces llegados a este punto vale la
pena reflexionar y cometer errores es
realmente un fracaso o es uno de los
caminos para el éxito
por la mirada tradicional nosotros ya
estamos acostumbrados a no cometer
errores solo pérez por el hecho de estar
tener miedo de ser criticados juzgados
incluso castigados por nuestros errores
yo siento que por cualquier error que
cometa voy a ser criticada
voy a ser clasificada
esta evaluación de nuestros propios
errores nos baja la autoestima y nos
vuelve más inseguros y lo peor es que a
veces juzgamos sin saber
por el otro lado por esta nueva mirada
de los errores
hoy hoy en día si una persona se
equivoca lo ideal lo correcto sería
aprender de este error pero qué pasa si
yo u otra persona no quiere aprender del
error podría pasar que la sociedad me
clasifiqué me critique de no aprender de
ello
en este punto surgen otras dos
cuestiones están todos aptos o
calificados para cometer errores
y se puede aprender de cualquier error
por ejemplo un ministro de economía se
equivoca y condena a millones de
personas a la pobreza o un médico que le
tenía que sacar un lunar a un paciente y
éste termina muerto tendrían ellos la
oportunidad de equivocarse
y si ellos aceptan el error se podría
considerar como un caso de aprendizaje y
nada más
estas miradas completamente opuestas y
contradictorias entre sí son las típicas
formas en las que se interpretan los
errores pero creería que ambas son una
carga digo esto porque en una tenemos el
miedo esa carga esa presión sobre
nuestras espaldas de no cometer errores
y por el otro lado tenemos esa es otra
vez esa carga esa presión
de aprender del error
creería que lo ideal sería construir un
tercer camino un camino que nos permita
sentirnos libres sentirnos sin esa
presión sin los condicionamientos del
éxito sin esas y sin las expertas
expectativas de los de la sociedad
hay una frase de ruso que me gusta me
gustó mucho cuando investigué sobre este
tema y dice el ser humano ha nacido
libre y sin embargo
vive por todas partes rodeado de cadenas
a lo largo del tiempo nosotros fuimos
capaces de romper cadenas que nos ataban
a pensar los fracasos los errores como
fracasos
sin embargo creo que nos hemos creado
nuevas cadenas
les propongo romper varias de estas
nuevas cadenas y experimentar la
posibilidad de hacer con nuestros
errores lo que queramos
[Aplausos]